Hi everyone, thank you
for joining us today
on our webinar on Seven Tips
for Motivating Middle School
and High School Kids
During Distance Learning.
My name is Dan Tu and I'll
be kicking us off today,
as well as moderating our Q and A portion
of today's segment.
Before we get started, there's
a couple of announcements
I'd like to make.
First of all, this
webinar is being recorded
and you will automatically
be emailed a copy of it
as well, we'll be posting this online
and available for your
review at your convenience.
So don't worry if you miss anything
or if you wanna go back
and watch something.
Secondly, we're really excited to announce
for the first time that we're
making this webinar available
in Spanish captioning.
So if you want, you can
go to this Bitly URL
that's also being entered
in our chat box right now.
So you can click to that.
And the way you'll see it
is just don't close out of this webinar,
you'll still be watching this webinar.
And that link will take
you to a captioning site
where you'll see the
translations as we speak,
or as close to possible as we speak.
And we'd also like to
thank several organizations
who've really helped us
with philanthropic support
which has enabled us to
bring new programming
like today's session.
So we wanna give a special
thanks to AT and T,
Bank of America, Google.org,
Fastly and Novartis.
With that, I'd like to introduce you all
to Kristen DiCerbo, who'll
be walking through the tips
and answering your live questions.
Kristen's our amazing
Chief Learning Officer.
She's also an expert in learning science,
and she's gonna be sharing
all of her expertise
with you today.
So with that, take it away Kristen.
- Great, thanks Dan.
And welcome too all of you.
Thanks so much for joining.
I know that raising
teenagers is difficult.
So one of the big jobs of a teenager
is to differentiate
themselves from their parents
and to think about who they
are outside of their family.
And that means that
sometimes it's really hard
to know what's going on with them
and they're trying on new identities
and they're trying new things.
So I'm not gonna tell you that
I have all the answers today.
Sorry, but hopefully I can
provide some strategies
that maybe you haven't thought of before,
other things to try, things
you might give a chance to.
There's nothing that's
gonna work for everyone.
gonna work for every kid,
but there's some things we
can all think about trying,
sharing to make things a little
bit easier for ourselves.
So with that disclaimer, I'll start off.
I'm gonna go through the tips
that are based on research
and what we know, and then let it go.
And Dan will ask some of the questions
that you guys are putting
into the questions piece
on the webinar, and we'll
have some time for Q and A.
So with that, when you
take all of the research
about motivation and think about, okay,
what is the big thing?
What are the big takeaways?
It turns out that it's pretty simple.
We're all motivated to do things.
When one, we expect to
be successful at them
and two, we value the activity.
So this probably makes sense.
Who wants to do things when
they think they're gonna fail
at them or not be successful?
And second we wanna do things that matter,
that are important to us.
Now, one of the tricks with teenagers,
is that the things they value are changing
and sometimes they're not communicating
the things that they value anymore.
And so that can make it difficult
to think about how do
you help them increase
their perceived value of an activity,
because it's not always clear.
So I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about ways to use that
lever of value and also ways
that we can help our students
feel like they're gonna be successful.
So if we think about all
of the rest of the tips
that I'm gonna give, they're
pretty much based on doing one
or both of these things.
So if you keep that in your mind,
even if these particular
tips aren't working,
you might think of other ways
that you can help students be successful
or help them really see
value in the activities
that they're being asked to do in school.
So one of the biggest things
that hits on both value
and the success is setting goals.
And the reason it's related to success
is because nothing makes you
feel like you can be successful
as having had some success in the past.
So if you set some short-term goals
and students are able to achieve those
they start to gain momentum.
They start to see themselves as learners.
And that can be really important
just in changing the mindset.
So think about for teenagers,
for kind of middle school
and high school students,
you don't wanna set a goal
that's gonna take longer than a week.
Because even at this age, more
than a week is a long time
to kind of be able to move through.
So if you do wanna set like
your goal for the month
or for the semester, you're
gonna wanna break that up
into pieces so that it's something
that there is a tangible
achievement pretty quickly.
So you start to get that feeling
of success and build that momentum.
And the other piece you
wanna do is find ways to know
if you're on track to meet that goal.
So if you have a weekly goal,
say, we're gonna try
to read three chapters
in this book by the end of the week,
think about what does that
break down to per day?
Think about that's a
way to monitor progress
so that then they know, are they on track?
Oh, I didn't quite read
that many pages yesterday
so I'm gonna read this many today.
Or I'm gonna read a few extra today
so I don't have to read as many tomorrow.
Those kinds of conversations are important
to help students build that
muscle of being able to think
about their own progress
and whether they're on track or not.
So we wanna keep, when we're
thinking about setting goals,
we don't wanna set too
many, keep them a few,
not more than three.
So think about short
goals, brief number of them
and goals that you can really measure.
So, you know when you've met them.
Which leads us to the next
piece, celebrate success.
So when students do meet their
goal, you wanna make sure
that that's a big message
that they're getting.
"Hey, you were successful."
So that can be a variety of things.
It can be your tone of voice
when you're talking about it.
It can be high fives and hugs.
It can be choosing what's for dinner.
We're gonna talk more
about tangible rewards
a little bit later.
But you're thinking
about ways to celebrate
when students do meet their goals
and also take that as a time to reflect.
So it's important when students are
and when they're not
successful to think about
what were the things that
helped them meet that goal?
What did they do that
helps them be successful?
Or what were the obstacles
that got in the way
so that they weren't successful?
And how can they think about
what they might do differently next time
or what they're gonna repeat next time
to be able to have success?
So that little bit of reflection
can be really important
for students to be able to get to that.
And both with setting
goals and reflecting,
you wanna bring the students in.
You don't wanna be as a parent
setting the goal for them.
You want to be working
with them to set goals.
And also when we're talking
about school and learning,
a good idea to connect with their teacher
to look at what their goals
that are already set out
by their teachers are so you can make sure
that that's all in lock step
with where students need to be.
So the other piece of reflection
is thinking about what happens,
what happened when they
maybe ran into trouble
or got stuck a little bit.
And that relates to the third tip
is helping to manage roadblocks.
So, sometimes particularly
with distance learning,
students will get to a place
where they just don't know
what to do next.
So, they're stuck and they
don't know what to do.
And then they get frustrated
and it starts to get them
to this kind of emotional spiral with it.
You wanna think about managing roadblocks
before they get to that point.
So when you were talking
about what are your goals
for the week, that's
the time to talk about,
so what are you gonna
do when you get stuck?
And they might even have
a little list of things
that they can refer to.
What to do when I get stuck.
How do they get help from you
if you are available when
they're working on their work?
I know lots of us are
also working from home
at the same time.
So what are the indicators that you have
when it's okay to ask you for help?
And hey, when you're on
a call and it's not okay
to ask for help.
Like being really specific
about how to get help from you.
How can they get help from their teacher?
How can they find help online?
How can they get help from their peers?
So all of those things
we should think about
what are the strategies that
they have when they get stuck.
Maybe one of the
strategies is to walk away
for a little bit and come back.
That's a good strategy
especially when you
start to feel frustrated.
So think about how to
manage those roadblocks
before they get in the situation
of needing to know what to do.
From there, you wanna think
about emphasizing that
effort leads to success.
So remember we talked about this idea
of feeling like you'll be successful.
But by early teens,
lots of kids already have some perceptions
of things they're just not good at.
And we wanna make sure and
try to break those ideas.
That even when we are
not maybe naturally good
at something, if we keep
practicing at it we'll get better.
And we actually have
on the Academy website,
a course called growth mindset
and in that there were
some pretty good videos
that talk about not just saying,
"Hey, you know, keep trying."
But the way our brains work,
there are cells in our brains,
we call them neurons.
And when we learn something new,
those neurons form new
connections with each other.
And so what practice does
and what even practice
when we're not succeeding,
even practice that we're getting wrong
helps to build those linkages.
And it's almost like when
you're lifting weights
and you can make this analogy
that your brain is a muscle.
And when you're lifting weight,
sometimes it's a little too heavy
and you can't quite lift that weight
but you go down a little
bit and you practice it that
and it builds up your muscles.
The same thing you practice at that level,
that's a little bit hard for you
and your brain is going
to make more connections.
If you just practice same
with lifting weights.
If you're just lifting
the two pound weights
and it's not really hard for you,
well, you're probably
not building your muscles
the same way if you're
just practicing stuff
you already know that super easy,
you're not making those
connections in your brain.
So we find that in the research
that when kids start to understand
a little bit about actually
there's biology basis
for trying things and working on things
that are kind of hard for you,
that actually motivates them to think
"Oh, I can be successful.
I can improve at this
thing that I'm doing."
So recommend checking
out some of those videos
but also thinking about how
to help your students see
that things aren't always easy.
And that learning actually is hard work
and that's okay, because
if they put in the work,
they're gonna get better at it.
So that's the fourth piece.
The fifth one is to encourage curiosity.
And this can be tough in
particular with teens and preteens.
And thinking about all of a
sudden, they're not interested
in the same things they
used to be interested in.
And so it can take some
work to try to figure out
what kinds of things are
they interested in now?
How do we help keep them thinking about,
I wonder how the world works.
So one thing you can do is
model that kind of thinking,
ask those questions out
loud, ask those things
like when you're riding your bike,
why does pedaling the
pedal move the big wheel?
All of these kinds of
things, how is this tree-
It doesn't seem to be getting any food.
How is it continuing to grow?
And what does that look like?
So if you're asking those
questions and modeling,
being curious about the world,
students will pick up on that
to those, "Oh, that is interesting."
And they'll start to find things
and it won't be everything.
And sometimes they'll roll their eyes
but as you keep trying and
keep putting things out there,
different things and
they'll start to kind of,
"Oh, maybe that is interesting."
Or start to have a
conversation about that,
or start to build on that.
So keep encouraging that sense
of interest and curiosity
in the world.
Because what this does, is
it increases that value piece
that I was talking about.
So if learning in school can
help you understand the world
and help you understand
things you're curious about,
then that's gonna increase that value
and make you more motivated
to do the activities
that you're doing related to school.
So next piece is related to that,
which is help to establish relevance.
So if you talk to teachers,
they will almost always say,
they hate the question when kids say,
"When will I ever need to learn this?"
But it turns out that when we
again think of that value side
of the equation, that
thinking about how something
is related to your interests, your goals,
what you might wanna be when you grow up,
related to learning something else
that you're interested in learning,
all of those things increase
the value of the activity
and make students more likely
to want to engage in it.
So those are important pieces
to think about how do we
establish that relevance?
So this comes back to knowing
what your kids' interests are
which can involve some detective work.
It can involve you observing them.
It can involve talking to
them, all those conversations.
Sometimes they're not gonna wanna talk
but that's okay. Keep going.
Persistence on your part is important too
and they will recognize that.
So thinking about how to
establish what is relevant
to your students, to your
kids, you'll have to figure out
what are their interests?
What are their things
that are important to them
to be able to help make those links?
But you have a better chance of doing that
than their teacher does.
So the more you can do
that the better impact
you're likely to have on their learning.
So next, then finally, we
talk a lot about rewards.
And we get a lot of
questions from parents,
like, "Is this bribing my kid?
I don't wanna bribe them to do their work.
They should want to do it."
Those kinds of things.
So a couple of pieces of guidance.
One is we all use rewards.
I know I use rewards for myself sometimes.
And I think about that when
I have to do a lot of writing
and it's kind of going slowly,
I'll say, "If I just finished this page,
I can give myself a Hershey's kiss."
I guess the little piece of
chocolate, not a big reward
but a little something
that's a reward for doing it.
We're not all intrinsically motivated
to do everything all the time.
Sometimes we need a little bit of boost.
And so rewards are used
and our best shoes, when they're
something that we can take
and get students going on a path.
So if it's something they don't
have any interest in doing,
a reward can be that little
boost that gets them started.
And once they get started,
they can start to again,
experience some success.
They can start to find
out interesting things.
They can start to see
themselves as learners.
But they need that little
boost to get going.
So rewards can definitely help do that.
They also don't have
to be tangible things.
They can be like spending time with you.
They can be spending
time with their friends.
They can be an extra
half hour on the computer
playing the video game
they're interested in.
It can be picking the movie.
It can be, picking what's for dinner.
All kinds of things can be rewarding.
They don't have to be a tangible something
that is money related to
cost and buying things.
So think about using
rewards to get things going,
keep them small, you can
brainstorm with your kid
about what things are rewarding to them.
And that can be good to come
up with a continuum of rewards.
If your student says, "Yeah,
a trip to Disney world."
That can be on one end,
it can go on the way bottom of the list
but I'm not gonna encourage using
those kinds of big rewards.
It really are not effective
because they require,
the "Hey, if you get A's
all year, you can get this."
It's just too long of a timeline
and too big of a stakes.
So you wanna do small things
so if they don't get it
then that's okay, because
they'll have another chance
which is the final thing
about using rewards.
It shouldn't be something
they either earn,
or they have no chance
of ever earning again.
It should be okay if you
didn't earn it this time,
we can set a new goal
and you can try to earn
it again the next time.
So you wanna think about
things that are small
and able to, if they don't
make it the first time
are able to try again
to earn those things.
So those are some of
the big tips and ideas
for thinking about generally again,
thinking about this balance
of how can we help kids
think they'll be successful
and how can we help them
value the activities
we're asking them to do.
So I will stop and pause there.
And Dan ask you to give us
some of the questions we have.
- Great, so thanks Kristen.
Before we get into the Q and A portion,
a couple of reminders for folks.
If you want a handout version
of this and go to webinar,
there's a handout section
with a link to this PDF
with these seven tips.
And then also we are already getting
a lot of great questions but
if you have any questions,
please put them in the question box.
There's a team of moderators,
kind of behind the scenes
putting in all the questions
and surfacing them up.
So go ahead and start
entering them right now.
So Kristen, we already had a
couple of questions come in.
One from email from a couple of days ago.
Question is from the Person S.
How do we get our older
kids not to play games
on their school issued devices
without policing them constantly?
It's a huge distraction and
very difficult to control.
We already have contacted
the school several times
about blocking some of these sites.
It's still an issue.
I mean I would assume for younger kids,
it's probably Minecraft,
for the middle kid
is probably Fortnight.
And then now it's the among us game.
So there's this all of
this constant distractions
that are available for the kiddos.
- Oh my gosh, I just saw
the Congress people playing
among us the other day.
Wow, that was crazy.
So there's a couple of
things here absolutely.
One of the challenges
of learning from home
is that there are so
many more distractions
and that it can be really
difficult to think about
okay, how do we help kids focus?
So there's a couple of ways
to kind of attack this issue.
One is, if I'm gonna keep
hitting on this goals piece.
If they have goals that are set
so that this is what they need to achieve,
then we wanna work with them
to make sure they're on track
to do that.
Then they'll think about,
okay, if I'm doing this,
does that get me off track
to meet the thing that I need to do?
I need to read 30 pages today.
All right, can I read 15
and then play a little bit
and then read 15 more?
Like have these kinds of conversations
with them about how they might
still be able to play some
if the plan is allowed at
all on the device side.
There's a couple of different
ways this might be going,
this question could be going.
like, if it's a games are
not allowed on the devices,
you probably need to think
about those technological
solution that block them.
But if gaming's allowed
but they need to be doing her schoolwork,
think about how you can
potentially set up schedules
that let them have some game time.
Like have a little bit
of game time have breaks?
Breaks are good.
We all need breaks.
And then they need to come back
from the break and think
about continuing their school.
And they're working with those are.
Those can be good ways to think
about teaching moderation,
think about teaching a little bit of that,
kind of control of what they're doing.
Set the timer for however
you know, 15 minutes
that they can play and then come back
to doing what they're doing
and think about what that is.
They've also told you,
this is a really rewarding
and interesting thing for me.
So if you can think about
how to use that as a reward
and turn it into a reward,
that that's something
that they're probably gonna work for
because that's where it is
and how to get it there.
Probably any other kind
of punitive measures
and all of that are not
gonna be that successful.
It's more like turning up the
dial on some of the schoolwork
and letting them have pieces of the game
at different times when it's appropriate
and help them figure out
how to make a schedule
that fits into to help those work.
So they can play a little bit.
- That's super helpful.
I love the suggestion of turning it
into part of the incentives piece.
Kristen, we have a
question from Nun who asks,
it's related to the goal.
So once after you've kind
of figured out the goal,
the question is, how
do you convince the kid
that achieving the goal
will lead to success?
A lot of the times the
kids don't believe you.
- So one thing is to set up
meeting the goal itself is success.
Like, if again, you're gonna try to do
35 practice problems on
factoring polynomials.
Like meeting that goal itself,
like doing 35 practice problems
and meeting polynomials,
that was a success in itself.
That's great.
So you wanna make that
itself an end point for them.
Like, that's really good
that they've done that.
So it's that piece that
then makes them feel like,
"Hey, so next week the math
challenge is gonna be adding
and subtracting polynomials."
But now you already were
successful at factoring them
so it's really likely that
you're gonna be successful
with adding and subtracting them
because you already were successful once.
This other thing that
was pretty hard to learn
and you did it.
So the key is to use kind
of their past successes
and their successes once they
in themselves are a success.
And then using those to build on those
of why they're likely to be
successful in future things.
- That's great. That's great.
Kristen, we have a question from Arlene
and the parent asks a question
that I think a lot of us have experienced.
One, I'm a parent of a high school
and a middle school counselor.
A lot of our students are
struggling with depression
and anxiety from being in
the house since last March.
They're not motivated and
upset because they're failing.
How can we motivate them
when they're mostly upset
from being in the house
for six plus months?
I think it's just really
important to recognize
that that's pretty normal.
I mean, I know that I've experienced
a little bit of that too,
during these last eight months.
- Absolutely, so the
first thing I'm gonna say
is that mental health is more important
than school progress.
So the first thing I
would say is, think about,
as you said, Dan, some amount
of just being mildly depressed
and a little bit anxious is pretty normal
in these kinds of times.
If you're finding that it
seems to be beyond a little bit
if it's really interfering
with their interactions
with your family, if
it's really interfering
with their just daily lives,
like they are not getting
out of bed, those kinds of signs,
I would absolutely
recommend professional help.
Talk to your pediatrician
is a good starting point.
Make sure to think
about what are the signs
of someone who's needing,
for whom this is a
little bit more than us.
This is tough.
So that's the first thing I would say
is know when to get help.
There's lots of good ways to check it.
But what psychologists usually look for
is when it starts to
interfere with your daily life
as kind of a good rule of thumb
for when it makes sense to get help.
But if it is like less than that
and it's, hey, I just am sad today.
I'm just feeling anxious today.
All of those things.
So first, as the parent is empathize.
Just like Dan just did,
"Hey, you know what?
I get it, this situation is no fun."
Like all of us are struggling
and it is totally okay to struggle.
I also encourage the way this was written
was being in the house.
It does help if you're in a place,
even if it's not with other people
to at least get some outside air
to go out and move and get some fresh air
if that's possible, where
you live and in your weather
and all of those kinds of things.
The next piece is that
exercise piece like moving,
it can be important and
can help kids get up.
So even if you're thinking
about the school day
they should have breaks
in their school day
where they are getting up
and moving and walking.
And I'm saying, this is
do as I say, not as I do,
I'm the worst.
I've been sitting in my chair
here for like eight hours.
But thinking about giving
up and moving is okay.
And if making sure some
of that's built in.
And the final thing that
teens really struggle with,
I think is the peer interaction
and the reduced peer interaction
they've had in these times.
So if there are ways that
you can help facilitate
whether that's online, video interactions,
whether that's, if you
have a small safe group,
I know some people are doing,
hey there's two other families
that we all have kind of the same view
on what's acceptable in terms of safety.
And we all get together.
Finding some ways that kids can connect
with other kids can be
helpful too in these times
that we've found.
So lots of different potential things
but empathize, definitely,
talk to your kids about it,
try to keep those doors open
so that they can talk to
you when they have concerns.
- That's great advice, thanks Kristen.
We have a question from
Barbara, who's asking advice
for kids who strive for
perfection, who are super motivated
but they are also, they
kind of are worried
about doing things that are imperfect
and that experience in
itself overwhelms them.
So how do you help those students?
I think some of the compartmentalizing
and making things more chunkable
that you've talked about earlier
was super super relevant for
this type of case as well.
- Yeah, definitely.
Thinking about how to
think about what is done,
what is acceptable on for
an assignment, what is okay.
And the other piece is
to really try to focus
on learning as opposed to grades.
So one of the things that often happens
with kids who kind of have
that perfectionist streak
is they really start to
focus on getting a hundred
or getting really that perfection piece.
And what do you wanna try
to do is to turn that focus
to what did you learn today?
What are the new skills you have?
What are the new ideas you understand?
And the more you can ask
questions about those things
and start to try to celebrate
learning something new
or getting a new skill or
being able to do something
you couldn't do before
and trying to get them
to focus on that piece, as
opposed to what was your grade
or score on this can be helpful
in reducing some of that perfection piece.
The other thing I would say
is to try to communicate
that failure is okay.
And failure is actually how we learn.
That gets back to some of that
growth mindset communication
that it's okay to not
be successful sometimes.
That helps us learn
and trying to help kids
be okay with that.
And interestingly for
all the talk about games,
games are actually pretty good at teaching
that it's okay to fail and you end up,
you can get your lives
back, you can start over.
It's all okay.
But kind of communicating about that idea
can be important too for kids.
- Nice, great, great Kristen.
One question we have
from Dennis who's asking,
remote learning's a big part
of this year's curriculum.
This allows for different
routines in the day.
Some days it's work from home.
Some days the kids can
work, stay in their pajamas
and take some classes.
What advice would you
have or how much emphasis
would you say in maintaining
a consistent routine
versus altering the routine?
- So good question.
Kids generally do thrive on routine
and knowing what to expect
and what's gonna come next.
But that doesn't mean
it has to be always the exact same thing.
So what I would advise
in terms of maintaining
is maintaining a schedule.
So at nine o'clock this happens,
at 10 o'clock this happens.
That it's written down is
usually helpful with visual cues.
So they can take a look at
it and really reference,
okay, here's, what's coming next.
Here's what's coming up today
for the rest of the day.
And so if that part is maintained,
like they know what's coming,
then you can flex a little bit
like other things, like
what are they wearing?
It's okay, if they're gonna think about.
And you can think even schools do this.
If you remember back too
when your kids were in elementary schools,
they probably did, it's
crazy day, it's pajama day.
All of those things are really good flexes
to make in the routine so it
doesn't just become monotonous.
And there's new things that they're doing.
I will say you also talked
about classes lounging
on the futon.
I have mixed feelings about that.
(both laughing)
It's good if kids have a space to learn.
That's kind of signals to them mentally,
I'm on now, because as we were talking
about all those other distractions,
if you're kind of trying to do school
in the same place that you
hang out and play video games
at night in the same place
that you're watching movies,
that's kind of not communicating,
"Hey, now's the time I need
to kind of tell my brain
it's time to focus on schoolwork."
So the more you can in terms of the place,
have some kind of a set place
that is communicating to them,
this is where the schoolwork happens
is probably a good idea.
But one class lounging on the futon.
One video isn't gonna hurt anyone.
- I love that.
I know for myself personally
I've been in this room for eight months.
And then I think once
a month I decide to go
to the kitchen or the dining room
and try to change things
up just a little bit.
- Yes, yes absolutely.
- Kristen, we have a follow-up
about the rewards and incentives.
So Kiki ask, "I've used
Fortnite as reward in the past
but they find that my son
rushes through his work
in order to quickly get
to playing this game.
So how do you get them to understand
that it's not just the quantity
but actually the quality of
the work that is important?"
- Well, it's a reward has to
be contingent on the quality.
So the reward can't just be
doing the 10 RAF problems.
It has to be doing the 10 math problems
and maybe explaining to
you why they're right.
If this starts depending
I know some math problems
right now there's probably
some math problems
I couldn't grade.
I wouldn't know if they
were right or wrong.
And some pre-calculus problems and things.
And so if it's the case where
you actually aren't sure
if they're right or wrong,
have your student explain them
to you and walk you through the steps.
And if he can do that, then he can play.
So it's definitely a matter
of trying to set that goal for quality.
If it's something that you can look at
and see if he's met a
quality standard great.
If not, having them explain it
to you and see if they've met
that kind of standard.
- I think this is one challenge
that I remember as a kid.
You have to finish your
homework before you get to play
with your friends and
you would just go home
and rush through your
homework just to go play
with your friends.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
So there it has to.
I know this puts burden on parents
to say you've got to
check it a little bit,
but if you're thinking about
rewards, you kind of do
otherwise you're gonna get
those unintended consequences.
- So Kristen, I think we
have time for maybe one
or two more.
We have a really good question from Ranga.
These recommendations require
parents to constantly engage
throughout the day.
Otherwise the children go back to playing,
whatever they like.
How are you kind of constantly engage?
I think this poses a question
where I don't know if you do
have to be constantly engaging.
I think the assumption here
is that you have to be
kind of with your child
the whole time.
I think part of your
recommendations that allows you
to free up some of that time.
So can you speak to how
do you kind of balance
the engagement and the
time that as a parent,
you have to do your day job.
- So first just let me recognize it.
It's absolutely we're asking way too much
with parents right now.
We are asking them to do multiple jobs
and not giving any break
on the amount of time
needed to do them.
But I do think that what you wanna do
is think about how you
can structure the day
so that they have set things
they're supposed to do
at set times.
And then you can do, check-ins
to see if they got those done.
And again, you wanna think
about positive reinforcement.
So you may have to start
off with very small chunks
but over time you can
gradually extend them.
So if you're thinking
about, at the beginning,
you may need to say okay,
here's what we're gonna do
in the next hour.
And if we get that done,
then you set the goal
for the next hour.
So that would require
like hourly check-ins.
But over time as they
start to again, see, okay,
what's our goal for the next two hours?
And again, using rewards
is not a bad thing.
Think about how you can
reward meeting those goals
that you set for those short time periods,
and then lengthen them over time
so that you don't have to
check in so frequently.
And they're still getting
that feeling of success
and staying on task.
- So I think we have time for one more.
And we have a couple of
questions around the same theme,
which is from Linda and Anika.
They're both wondering
what ideas do you have
for students who sees
zero value in school?
Or if they they're just the
kids desire to fit in socially
causes them to kind of
degress academically.
- Yeah, they're probably a bit separate
but so if your kid is really
motivated by social things
you wanna think about
how to tie social things
into learning, how to provide
social learning experiences.
Are there small study
groups, even if the two kids
are just on their computers
and have the video on,
but aren't studying together.
There's just like some
social interaction there.
Can you think about having
them access to peers?
Is this something that's
rewarding for them?
So find ways to give them
that social experience,
but tie it into also learning goals
and being able to learn
together with their peers
and what they're doing.
So that's kind of the social piece.
The other piece for kids
who just don't see the value
of school is the toughest
thing about teenagers
is probably for those who
it's tough to figure out
what they are interested in.
But that's my advice is to figure out
what does interest them?
What are the things that they value?
What are the things that
are interesting to them?
Is it working on old cars?
Is it baking?
What is something that they like to do?
And then think about how you can tie in
things they're learning in
school to that piece of things.
I use baking a lot because
it's easy to set up.
There's a lot of math in baking
and you can kind of make
some of those ties in there.
But the key is to think
about what are the things
that are interesting and
trying to make those links,
whether it's future careers,
whether it's learning something
that helps them be better at
that thing that they're doing.
Relating their physics lessons,
to things that are going on.
Whatever that is that
they're interested in.
And it can be tough to figure out.
Sometimes teenagers can
seem pretty apathetic
about a lot of stuff and
don't wanna show their parents
when they're interested in things.
But again, put on your detective
hat so you can figure out
what it is that they are interested in
and it starts with trying to
build some of those bridges.
- That's wonderful.
Unfortunately, that's all the time we have
for questions today.
And so Kristen, thank you
for sharing your expertise
with our audience.
And we wanna thank you all
you busy parents out there.
We know it's an incredibly busy time
and you're balancing a lot.
So we wanna thank you for
joining our session today.
A couple of reminders,
if you missed anything
or you wanna review, by
registering for this webinar
you'll automatically be
emailed this recording.
If you wanna download the PDF as well
that'll automatically be sent to you.
And we will be also be posting this
in YouTube afterwards as well.
So you'll have multiple chances to go back
and look at some of the
content if you missed anything.
And then secondly, we have
a lot of resources available
on our
keeplearning.khanacademy.orgmicrosite
which it has all of our
distance learning materials
in one place.
And then before we sign
off, we wanna ask you
to do two things for us.
First, there's a poll that will pop up
and we will be asking you
how could we make future iterations
of this session more useful for you?
And then secondly, we
will ask you your advice
on what kinds of sessions would you like
to see us build on next?
So please let us know.
This was actually a result
of some of your feedback
in the past as well.
And we're totally here to
support you in any way we can.
So from all of us at Khan
Academy, thank you again
for joining us and have
a great, great evening.